m
et
monsieur et monsieur
c'est moi
le tableau de la dame à sa toilette
j'ai été peints au 16e
vous manierez n'est ce pas échouer suis
heureux
et pourtant je ne suis pas le seul objet
de votre satisfaction
regardez bien le cadre qui me porte
il est magnifique non
et je trouve qu'on n'y prête pas assez
attention
c'est bien dommage
cela tient sans doute au fait que l'on
ne connaît pas ou assez mal et l'art du
bois doré
e
on
le bois doré un monde de vieille
tradition de patience et de sagesse
oh
mais tenait
suivez mon c'est là que les cadors mais
aussi les sculptures les retables les
miroirs que celle encore viennent
retrouver le bonheur d'une deuxième
jeunesse sous les doigts d'or de
l'artisan je vais d'ailleurs vous
montrer comment ils revivent l'âge d'or
dois je vous dire dès maintenant que ce
qu'ils préfèrent en général dans leur
longue restauration
c'est le moment où l'artisan d'horreur
pose une à une les feuilles d'or sur
leurs bois mais non reprenons calmement
et dans l'ordre les différentes phases
de leur résurrection avant la pause de
laure proprement dite le d'horreur doit
se livrer à un you ému ce travail de
préparation c'est l'art paru le
traitement que le d'horreur leur fait
subir pendant la première phase de l'art
parure est plutôt pénible
rendez vous compte on les recouvre d'une
bonne dizaine de couche d'apprêt d'abord
avec du blanc poché au pinceau après
qu'on les ait en coller avec une
décoction de vinaigre de celle de
feuilles d'absinthe mais de code
afexa on doit se sentir en harmonie
art
on
leblanc sert à enrober la sculpture pour
que la feuille d'or appliquée sur des
formes douces des mois et demi lui
trouve c'est meilleur effet
ce n'est qu'à frais quand le blanc
devient lisse et durs comme du marbre
qu'ont fait les reprises aux gros blanc
la mastication est un apprentissage
difficile il faut y est là prêt avec de
la salive
mais plus on mange de gros blanc et plus
on devient vieux
la seconde phase l'art parure sera pour
eux plus agréable sous les faire réparer
leur relief sera de nouveau ce épuré et
ils retrouveront peu à peu les
principaux éléments de rupture
être d'horreur
c'est ont fait exercé cinq métiers tour
à tour il doit être menuisier ébéniste
parce qu'il y a des formes et des
assemblages souvent complexes à
restituer dans la plupart des cadres
anciens
sculpteur ensuite
le bois doré des siècles passés et en
une véritable dentelle sculpté il
effleure var qui nous pas une partie
endommagée la de doreur doit retrouver
le motif original en même temps qu'il
cherchera à adapter le plus parfaitement
possible le cadre au tableau de façon à
en faire ressortir les qualités pour
cela il doit faire appel à ses
connaissances indispensables de
l'histoire de l'art le bois doré à ces
époques
ces écoles comme la peinture
je voulais dire c'est le moment préféré
par les objets en cours de restauration
d'abord le d'horreur résine avec un
espèce de pinceau qui porte un drôle de
nom c'est le mieux héroux cela veut bien
dire ce que cela veut dire
le d'horreur les arrondis auparavant
d'une terre dit lui connaît rebelles
bold armés selon un procédé eux deux 8
siècles
c'est bien ça
et ça n'a pas changé depuis qu'on dort
loin le d'horreur passe rapidement la
palette de martres sur ses cheveux quand
il en a pour la chargée en électricité
statique
il prend ensuite la feuille d'or avec la
palette ainsi électrisée par le coussin
adoré fait de parchemin et de daim
le parchemin la peau de daim je trouve
que nous plongeons en plein moyen-âge
n'est ce pas comme avec cet outil au nom
bien vite aurait ce que je veux dire
l'api lieu de petits cris grâce auquel
le d'horreur mettant place à fruit d'or
bonne habits de fête
enfin voici le passage de la pierre
d'agate en dents de loup qui viendra
donner au rayon insolite la définit un
vrai plaisir
l'art du d'horreur est donc là aussi
parce brunissage minutieux qui vient
rendre alors son brillant
vous avez fini merlini oui oui mais
c'est bien joli vous l'avez mater
maintenant oui c'est ma fille qui est
bon on va passer à la patine la patine
de la dorure
c'est bien sûr de brodeur lab les
premiers micro d'europe 1 bernard de
laval et ses compagnons la véritable
signature de l'artisan voilà on arrive à
la patine on a fini le travail
l'apothéose puis c'est le grand jeu on
s'amuse on met des couleurs on vice mais
on valse du début jusqu'à la fin
d'ailleurs sans ce métier une grande
valse sans arrêt on s'arrête pas une
valse qui pourrait aller à beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes malheureusement le le
métier se perd un peu
on a peur de devenir artisan faudrait le
monter un petit peu tout ça
voilà un petit peu d'éclat un petit peu
d'essence pour faire revivre son oeuvre
ou plutôt on laisse ça un petit peu
c'est l'âge
l'objet a pris un siècle de siècle d'un
seul coup en cinq minutes et voilà
e
bonnart
un métier que l'auto rur préférerait
toutefois user à la création plutôt qu'à
la restauration mais de toute façon fait
le bonheur des bois doré
m
on
obama
bon
non